let us now discuss in some more detail
what it takes to carry out Bayesian
inference when both random variables are
discrete the unknown parameter theta is
a random variable that takes values in a
discrete set and we can think of these
values as alternative hypothesis in this
case we know how to do inference we have
in our hands the Bayes rule and we have
seen plenty of examples so instead of
going through one more example in detail
let us assume that we have a model that
we have observed the value of x and that
we have already determined the
conditional pmf of the random variable
theta as a concrete example suppose that
theta can take values 1 2 or 3 we have
obtained our observation and the
conditional pmf takes this form we could
stop at this point or we could continue
by asking for a specific estimate of
theta our best guess as what theta is
one way of coming up with an estimate is
to use the maximum a posteriori
probability rule which looks for that
value of theta that has the largest
posterior or conditional probability in
this example it is this value so our
estimate is going to be equal to 2 an
alternative way of coming up with an
estimate could be the LMS rule which
calculates an estimate equal to the
conditional expectation of the unknown
parameter given the observation that we
have made this is just the mean of this
conditional distribution in this example
it would fall somewhere around here and
the numerical value as you can check is
equal to 2 point 2 next we may be
interested in how good a certain
estimate is and for the case where we
interpret the values of theta as
hypotheses a relevant criterion is the
probability of error in this case
because we already have some data
available in our
and were called to make an estimate what
we care about is the conditional
probability given the information that
we have that we're making an error
making an error means the following we
have the observation the value of the
estimate has been determined it is now a
number and that's why we write it with a
lowercase theta hat but the parameter is
still unknown we don't know what it is
it is described by this distribution and
there is a probability that it's going
to be different from our estimate what
is this probability it depends on how we
construct the estimates if in this
example we use the map rule and we make
an estimate of to the risk probability
point six that the true value of theta
is also equal to 2 and we are fine but
there is a remaining probability of 0.4
that the true value of theta is
different than our estimate so there's
probability point 4 of having made a
mistake if instead of an estimate equal
to 2 we had chosen an estimate equal to
3 then the true parameter would be equal
to our estimate with probability point 3
but we would have made an error with
probability point 7 which would be a
bigger probability of error more
generally the probability of error of a
particular estimate is the sum of the
probabilities of the other values of
theta and if we want to keep the
probability of error small we want to
keep the sum of the probabilities of the
other values small which means we want
to pick an estimate for which its own
probability is large and so by that
argument we see that the way to achieve
the smallest possible probability of
error is to employ the map rule and this
is a very important property of the map
rule now this is the conditional
probability of error given that we
already have data in our hands but more
generally we may want to compare
estimators or talk about their
performance
in terms of their overall probability of
terror we're designing a decision-making
system that's going to process data and
making decisions in order to say how
good our system is we want to say that
overall whenever you use the system
there's going to be some random
parameter there's going to be some value
of the estimate and we want to know
what's the probability that these two
will be different we can calculate this
overall probability of error by using
the total probability theorem and the
conditional probabilities of error as
follows we condition on the value of x
for any possible value of x we have a
conditional probability of Terror and
then we take a weighted average of these
conditional probabilities of error there
is also an alternative way of using the
total probability theorem which would be
to first condition on theta and
calculate the conditional probability of
error for a given choice of this unknown
parameter and both of these formulas can
be used which one of the two is more
convenient really depends on the
specifics of the problem finally we
would like to make an important
observation we argued that for any
particular choice of an observation the
map rule achieves the smallest possible
probability of error so under the map
rule this term is as small as possible
for any given value of the random
variable capital X since each term of
this sum is as small as possible under
the map rule it means that the overall
sum will also be as small as possible
and this means that the overall
probability of error is also smallest
under the map
in this sense the map rule is the
optimal way of coming up with estimates
in the hypothesis testing context where
we want to minimize the probability of
error